my nickname is the armless Archer I
don't want to be known as the sideshow
as they say I want to be known as the
best archer in the world I want to do
whatever it takes to become that guy
there was no medical reason for why I
was born this way they did a bunch of
tests they couldn't find any drugs or
medications or anything like that so in
a sense I'm just kind of like the
lottery winner as they say I couldn't
find a job people would hire me my wife
was the one make you know paying the
bills and I didn't feel like I was doing
my job taking care of my kids and
supporting my wife so I talked her into
letting me get a bow so I could
literally go out teach myself how to
shoot harvest an animal and put food on
the table with the meat from it that
made me feel awesome
it made me feel like I was doing
something to help the family and went to
an archery tournament and I did I think
I got 200 place out of 500 people which
isn't very good but they all had arms I
was like wow I'm pretty good at this and
I haven't even practiced much but if I
got practice and training you know and
sat in the chair eight hours a day and
tried everything I taught myself how to
shoot I taught myself what's it like had
been a pressure and and I just kept
shooting it and pretty soon I'm at
trials and I shoot trials and win by so
many points that I missed the world
record by two points and I find myself
on the way to London and I knew this was
my call and this is what I need to do in
2012
the London Paralympic Games I was the
new guy coming in no one knew who Matt
Stutzman was up to that point I had only
been to one international tournament
ever
who is this guy without arms thinking
they're just gonna roll into the gates
and do well I ended up getting the
silver medal locking my name in as one
of the best archers in the world 2012
the medal that I won shooting against
people with hands pretty cool the silver
medal is great but for me looking at the
medal I still kind of have that like
error frustration because silver is the
only metal you have to lose to win so
I'm super focused I told myself after
that games like I got to push myself
even harder it doesn't matter who it is
I'm going to beat them do my process and
hopefully win the gold medal
the Guinness World Records I hold is the
longest accurate archery shot so I hit a
standard feat of target at 310 yards and
that is the Guinness world record for
anybody we're not putting me in a
Paralympic category at this point we're
saying out of everyone in the entire
world that has ever shot a bow I hold
that record I really thrive on competing
against the best able-body archers in
the world as well I just want to prove
to the world that I can be the best out
of everyone when I wake up for the day I
think for myself you know I'm lucky to
be here I have a lot of things that a
lot of other people don't have and I'm
not gonna let that go to waste what can
I do today to improve on yesterday and
that's why I think use that as
motivation